AND WE WILL GIVE YOU ALL THE
DETAILS.
THAT AND MORE AND ARE VERY
IMPORTANT BREAKING NEWS OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
AS WE SPEAK, THE SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO IS IN THE AIR
WITH THREE RELEASED AMERICAN
HOSTAGES WERE ON THEIR WAY BACK
THANKFULLY TO THE UNITED STATES
AFTER SPENDING MONTHS INSIDE
HARD LABOR PRISON CAMPS ACROSS
NORTH KOREA.
THIS WAS A MAJOR DIPLOMATIC WIN
FOR THE PRESIDENT AND THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND A VERY
IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD FOR
NORTH KOREA.
MOST IMPORTANT, THREE AMERICAN
LIVES THANKFULLY WERE SAVED.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP'S HISTORIC
SUMMIT WITH KIM JONG UN IS NOW
MOVING FORWARD, AS PLANNED.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I APPRECIATE KIM JONG UN
DOING THIS AND ALLOWING THEM TO
GO.
WE PICKED A TIME.
WE PICKED A PLACE FOR THE
MEETING.
OR SUMMIT, AS YOU LIKE TO CALL
IT.
I THINK IT WILL BE VERY
SUCCESSFUL, BUT AS I ALWAYS SAY,
WHO KNOWS.
WHO KNOWS WHAT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
IT'S GOING TO BE A VERY
IMPORTANT EVENT.
AGAIN, I THINK THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT NOBODY THOUGHT WAS GOING TO
HAPPEN FOR YEARS OR MORE.
>> WHERE IS THE SUMMIT GOING TO
TAKE PLACE?
>> WE WILL ANNOUNCE THAT WITHIN
THREE DAYS.
WE ARE WORKING ARRANGEMENTS.
>> DO YOU DESERVE THE NOBEL
PRIZE, DO YOU THINK?
>> EVERYONE THINKS SO BUT I
WON'T SAY IT.
I WANT TO GET IT FINISHED.
THE PRIZE I WANT IS VICTORY FOR
THE WORLD, NOT FOR EVEN HERE.
I WANT VICTORY FOR THE WORLD
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT.
THAT'S THE ONLY PRIZE I WANT.
>> Sean: 88 HAS BEEN SET FOR
THE UPCOMING MEETING BETWEEN
TRUMP AND KIM JONG UN AND
WE WILL LET YOU KNOW THE DETAILS
AS WE GET THEM HERE LET ME BE
CLEAR.
THIS DIPLOMATIC PROGRESS, IT'S
NO ACCIDENT.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK THE
REINS FROM BARACK OBAMA, LITTLE
ROCKET MAN WAS LAUNCHING
BALLISTIC MISSILES OVER JAPAN.
HE WAS THREATENING GUAM,
THREATENING THE REST OF THE
WORLD.
OF COURSE, TESTING NUCLEAR
WEAPONS LEFT AND RIGHT AND OF
COURSE BALLISTIC MISSILES.
NOW ALL OF THESE AGGRESSIVE
TACTICS TO HAVE ENDED.
AT LEAST FOR THE MOMENT.
THIS, THANKS TO THE HARD WORK,
NEGOTIATING SKILLS OF THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS BRAND-NEW
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO.
AFTER TIGHTENING SANCTIONS,
DEVELOPING A STRONG RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA AND
THREATENING TO INTRODUCE NEW
TARIFFS, SENDING MULTIPLE
CARRIER STRIKE GROUPS TO THE
REGION, AND BERATING KIM JONG UN
ON THE WORLD STAGE, THE
NORTH KOREAN DICTATOR IS NOW
LIMPING TO THE NEGOTIATING
TABLE.
IT IS ON THE TERMS THE
UNITED STATES SET.
WAIT, HANG ON.
REMEMBERS A FEW MONTHS AGO YOUR
CORRUPT MEDIA WAS TELLING YOU
DONALD TRUMP WAS LEADING US TO A
NUCLEAR WAR WITH NORTH KOREA.
HOW COULD THEY EVER GET
SOMETHING LIKE THAT WRONG?
TYPICAL.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE IDEA OF A NUCLEAR
SHOWDOWN WITH NORTH KOREA KEEPS
YOU UP AT NIGHT, I WOULD
RECOMMEND DELETING YOUR TWITTER
APP.
>> NOT MERELY BEING CAVALIER
WITH THE THREAT ABOUT NUCLEAR
WAR.
HE'S BEEN CAVALIER IN A WAY THAT
MAKES HIM SEEM DEMENTED.
>> THESE ARE THE MESSAGES FROM A
PERSON WHO IS NOT WELL, FROM A
LEADER WHO IS NOT FIT FOR
OFFICE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOADING
KIM JONG UN TO TEST A NUCLEAR
MISSILE AGAIN, TO PROVE ITS
RELIABILITY, TO SHOW HIM WRONG.
FUNDAMENTALLY I THINK IT COMES
ACROSS AS TWO KINDERGARTNERS WHO
ARE JOSTLING EACH OTHER, EXCEPT
THAT EACH HAS NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> TOO LATE AFTER 100,000
AMERICANS DIE.
>> AFTER A NUCLEAR HOLOCAUST.
>> OR AFTER A MILLION DIE.
>> THAT'S WHERE WE ARE.
IT'S NOT AN EXAGGERATION.
>> EXPERTS ARE WORRIED HE COULD
INADVERTENTLY TRIGGER A
CATASTROPHE.
>> Sean: THE TYPICAL MEDIA
BARRAGE DIDN'T END WELL OR AGE
WELL.
I ONE OF THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA,
ARE THEY GOING TO APOLOGIZE FOR
THE HYSTERICAL COVERAGE, JUST
LIKE THEIR PHONY RUSSIAN
COVERAGE, LIKE EVERYTHING ELSE I
GET WRONG?
IT'S UNLIKELY BECAUSE JUST
YESTERDAY, YES,
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THE PAPER
OF RECORD, THEY ACTUALLY SLAMMED
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE POMPEO
BECAUSE HE WAS ABSENT DURING
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL ANNOUNCEMENT.
THEN THEY FOUND OUT HE WAS
ACTUALLY NORTH KOREA RESCUING
AND SAVING AMERICAN HOSTAGES.
SOMETHING BARACK OBAMA COULD
NEVER GET DONE.
TRUMP RESPONDED TWO HOURS AGO ON
TWITTER, HE WROTE: "THE FEELING
"NEW YORK TIMES" CRITICIZE THE
SECRETARY OF STATE, POMPEO, FOR
BEING MISSING, WHEN HE WAS
FLYING TO NORTH KOREA.
FAKE NEWS SO BAD."
WE WILL GET BACK TO THE
ABUSIVELY BIASED MEDIA IN A
MOMENT BUT FIRST WE ARE ALSO
FOLLOWING VERY CLOSELY A
DEVELOPING SITUATION INSIDE OF
IRAN.
THE IDF IS REPORTING THAT
ISRAEL'S ABLE TO INTERCEPT
MULTIPLE ROCKETS FIRED BY
IRANIAN SOURCES FROM A SYRIAN
SYRIAN-BASED.
NO INJURIES HAVE BEEN REPORTED.
I JUST GOT OFF THE PHONE WITH A
HIGH-RANKING ISRAELI OFFICIAL
WHO IS NOW CONFIRMED TO ME THIS
WAS IN RESPONSE TO ISRAEL'S
MILITARY ACTIONS, AND IN FACT I
HAVE CONFIRMATION ISRAEL TONIGHT
NOT LONG AGO HAS RETALIATED.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE MORE OF
THAT IN THE MOMENT WITH COLONEL
OLIVER NORTH.
YESTERDAY PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE
THE IMPORTANT DECISION TO PULL
AMERICA OUT OF THE INCREDIBLY
FLAWED IRANIAN NUCLEAR DEAL.
IN A FEW WEEKS, U.S. SANCTIONS
AGAINST IRAN WILL BE REINSTATED,
LIKELY SQUEEZING THE ROGUE
NATION ECONOMICALLY AND
ESSENTIALLY IRAN WILL NOW HAVE
LESS MONEY TO FUND, LET'S SEE,
THEIR PROXY WARS IN SYRIA, IRAQ,
YEMEN.
THEY ARE FUNDING OF TERRORISM
AROUND THE WORLD, WEAPON SYSTEM
AIMED AT ISRAEL AND OTHER
ALLIES.
OF COURSE THE CORRUPT ISLAMIC
NEXT POLITICAL LEADERS IN IRAN
AND THE MULLAHS, THEY ARE NOT
TAKING THE SOIL.
PETULANT IRANIAN LAWMAKERS
YELLING ONCE AGAIN DEATH TO
AMERICA FROM THE PARLIAMENT
FLOOR.
EVEN BURNING AN AMERICAN FLAG.
AS YOU CAN SEE, IN OTHER WORDS,
A PRETTY NORMAL TUESDAY FROM THE
PARLIAMENT IN TEHRAN.
MEANWHILE, IRAN'S SUPREME LEADER
WENT ON A TOTALLY UNHINGED
TWITTER WRAPPED SAYING THE U.S.
PRESIDENT SHALLOW, LUDICROUS
BEHAVIOR WASN'T UNEXPECTED.
THE SAME BEHAVIOR EXISTED IN
PREVIOUS U.S. PRESIDENTS YET
IRANIAN NATION IS PERSISTING
WHILE FORMER U.S. PRESIDENTS
PASSED AWAY AND THE ISLAMIC
REPUBLIC OF IRAN IS STILL
STANDING.
THIS MAN CORPSE WILL ALSO BE
WORM FOOD WHILE THE IS LONGBOAT
REPUBLIC STAND STRONG.
COMING FROM A MAN
PRESIDENT OBAMA, THINK ABOUT
THIS, TRUSTED AND HANDED OVER
$150,000,000,000.02.
A PROMISE HE GOT BACK.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO BUILD NUKES
BUT WE GOT HE GOT TO CONTINUE TO
SPIN THOSE CENTRIFUGES.
NATURALLY, THE MULLAHS OF IRAN
ARE THREATENING TO RAMP UP THE
URANIUM ENRICHMENT PROGRAM.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS NOT BOWING
DOWN TO THE EMPTY THREATS.
>> WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO IF
IRAN STARTS UP THEIR NUCLEAR
PROGRAM?
>> THEY WILL FIND OUT.
I DON'T THINK THEY SHOULD DO
THAT.
I WOULD ADVISE IRAN NOT TO START
THEIR NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
I WOULD ADVISE THEM VERY
STRONGLY.
IF THEY DO, THERE WILL BE VERY
SEVERE CONSEQUENCE.
>> Sean: SADLY, IRAN'S MORALLY
CORRUPT POLITICAL LEADERS AREN'T
THE ONLY ONES MELTING OUT OF THE
PRESIDENT'S DECISION.
YOUR VERY OWN MAINSTREAM MEDIA
THEY ARE ALSO IN FREAK OUT MODE
YET AGAIN.
I GUESS THEY DIDN'T LEARN FROM
THEIR NORTH KOREAN COVERAGE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> DECISION BY THE PRESIDENT
THAT SOME SAY MARKS THE
UNITED STATES' BIGGEST
SELF-INFLICTED FOREIGN POLICY
WOUND SINCE THE IRAQ WAR.
>> WHAT WE HEARD WAS NOT FOREIGN
POLICY.
IT WAS VANDALISM.
>> DOESN'T THIS GIVE IRAN A
PROPAGANDA WIN?
>> OF COURSE.
>> I GUESS THE GOOD NEWS HERE IS
THAT JOHN BOLTON IS FINALLY
GETTING THE WAR HE HAS ALWAYS
WANTED.
>> REINFORCES THE NOTION THAT WE
ARE SOMETHING OF A ROGUE
COUNTRY, THAT WE DON'T UNDER OR
-- HONOR OR LIVE UP TO OUR
INTERNATIONAL COMMITMENTS >> IS
HE KEEPING A CAMPAIGN PROMISE
CUSTOMER DOES HE KNOW WHAT HE
PULLED OUT OF?
>> THE TOTALITY OF THIS
PRESIDENT'S BEHAVIOR AND
DECISIONS LEADS ME TO QUESTION
WHY HE DOES ANYTHING AND WHETHER
OR NOT IT IS TO DEFLECT FROM
SOMETHING ELSE.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS THE MORAL
COMPASS TO MAKE A DECISION BASED